what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering the current run of the
defenders kind of normally i don't
really do this normally i kind of wait
until a story arc finishes or at least i
try to wait until a story arc finishes
and then cover it but this one's
particularly interesting um i don't know
how long it's gonna take for marvel to
finish this probably about another three
months but it's really really cool
because i feel like this is one of the
things that marvel does it's going to
have effects on the future of the marvel
cinematic universe right so the way this
opens up is initially with just doctor
strange doing doctor strange stuff right
hanging upside down reading tarot cards
it's a normal day for stephen strange
right you know he's just doing his thing
he's literally practicing like magic
stuff in his his pajamas right so you
know
dr strange being doctor strange but
suddenly he's met by the arrival of the
masked raider now the mass raider is an
interesting concept this is one of those
weird things i want to say the
masquerader played a role in the 2019
one-shot marvel incoming which marvel
never did anything with because no one
really cared so marvel was kind of like
huh you know
we'll sweep it under the carpet that's
basically what happened right i'm not
aware that they actually did anything
with it uh and in fact you probably
forgot about it until i just brought it
up
but the important thing here is that the
masked raider is a title that different
people have had over the years in marvel
comics technically speaking the original
mass raider appeared in marvel comics
number one back in 1939 yes before it
was marvel comics they actually had a
line called marvel comics the publisher
was called timely comics and then timely
became atlas and then under really stan
lee atlas became marvel comics uh but
back in the 1930s they had a comic that
was called marvel comics number one this
is actually where stan lee got the idea
from to rebrand as marvel comics itself
but the important thing here is that
while the original masked raider had the
eternity mask the eternity mask wasn't
really fleshed out until years later and
the way this works is that eternity's
mask is quite literally a part of the
being eternity itself and the person who
wears it will become equal to whoever it
is they're fighting against now they
become equal in all facets right every
aspect of that and we'll talk about the
significance of that as we get further
in this story the important thing here
is that when stephen strange faces off
against the mass trader there are two
things going on one stephen strange is
aware of eternity's mask he knows what
it is he knows that it was a mask that
was basically assembled by the knights
of king arthur right arthur pendragon
basically cultist leaders and things
like that it's appeared and disappeared
over the years the most recent use of
eternity mask had actually fallen in the
hands of the enclave the organization
that created adam warlock and more
recently had recreated uh michael korvac
but that the mask itself is one of these
artifacts that's highly obscure but
those who know about it are always
looking for it because if you put on
eternity mask and then you fought the
incredible hulk you would be equal to
the incredible hulk and in fact your
strength would actually increase as the
incredible hulk's strength increases you
would probably end up beating him
because you're able to think in a way
the incredible hulk's just not able to
do if the eternity mask is put on and
they fight doctor strange like what's
happening here they basically end up
going toe-to-toe with steven strange now
the big difference here this is one of
the things that steven strange notices
the big difference here is having power
equal to steven strange is completely
different than being able to use power
in the same manner as steven strange and
that's one of the things that he notices
is the mass raider is adept at using
magic right he knows how to use the
power of steven strange and so seemingly
the mast raider is someone that he that
is familiar with doctor strange now the
caveat to this is that doctor strange
uses the eye of agamotto which as we
know historically allows him to
basically see everything he cannot see
who this guy is so it was kind of a
mystery who's the masked raider but it
was enough that stephen strange actually
had to essentially cast a spell that
would basically strip away their ability
to use any of the powers they have and
basically devolve into bare knuckle
fighting and ultimately because steven
strange has some measure of martial arts
training he's able to overcome this guy
right and so once everything kind of
calms down they kind of start having a
discussion and it's like what's going on
here right like why are you here what's
the whole idea behind this what we're
basically told is that somewhere along
the line when the enclave was in the
process of creating atom four also known
as the recreated uh michael korvac which
we covered in our our videos on the more
recent run of iron man that mass trader
was there the whole time but the reason
why had nothing to do with michael
korvac instead what he was aware of is
the fact that the enclave was going to
initiate something called the reset
protocol and that the information that
the master raider had basically either
deduced or had been given to him is that
the reset protocol was time travel that
the goal of the enclave was to go back
in time and to create a universe of pure
science now that really falls part and
parcel with the role of the enclave and
this is one of those things that might
fall on people as being kind of strange
if you're unfamiliar with the enclave
right so we've talked about it before
but honestly i think we've talked about
it so infrequently and i think it's
obscure enough we could probably do with
a little bit of an explanation here most
likely because you'll end up seeing the
enclave in the marvel cinematic universe
but the enclave is basically an
organization of scientists who believe
in dominating the world and really
ruling it through technological means
right they almost treat technology as a
kind of religion they're sort of a cult
to technology itself now the the real
first attempt to achieve this was
creating him who you guys know as adam
warlock adam warlock was basically a
kind of engineered perfect being and
then of course adam warlock escaped and
just kind of been out in marvel comics
ever since right so the enclave has
never really been successful in their
endeavors and in fact this is about as
close as it could possibly be the reason
why this matters and why it's so
significant is because zoda who's
basically the leader of the enclave ends
up basically working to cast what's in
effect time travel magic and so of
course the spell book itself is shot by
the masked raider to keep zoda from
being able to complete the spell but in
the final page that falls we get a
picture of psy's neck now this is the
important thing here because seismic was
a ridiculously overpowered magic wielder
i mean this guy this guy was so broken
check this out this guy was so
incredibly broken they did a whole bunch
of things with him right he was from the
future he was a person that learned to
use magic he mastered time travel
through magical means when all the way
back to the beginning of time and it
actually amassed so much magical energy
he could have recreated the universe and
he did right but instead of making
himself ruler he just kind of became the
origin point of the universe itself and
then just kind of dispersed himself and
that was it right literally he was like
michael korvac right the guy was so
powerful he had to end his own existence
it was ridiculous how op he was to give
you guys perspective man like if if if
seismic came back now in marvel comics
at the height of his power very few
people would be able to stand against
cosmic entities would struggle against
seismic this guy was just ridiculously
powerful the fact that seis nag is
what's referred to as the father of time
travel magic basically indicates to
steven strange that whatever it is
that's going on here right like this
kind of of chaos that's ensued when
magic ran wild is going to affect the
time stream and so in order to keep this
from happening doctor strange does
something interesting because of the
fact that no pun intended uh time is
running out
and their backs are against the wall
what he does is he goes to kind of a
somewhat old-school way of doing things
he forms a team in the same way that he
used to with the secret defenders what
does that mean okay so you guys are
aware of the defenders team itself at
least most of you guys are why the
original iteration of the team was
doctor strain silver surfer the
incredible hulk name with a submariner
and then eventually valkyrie and a few
other characters here and there the
original defenders was highly popular
people loved it marvel ended up
canceling it after 125 issues they
brought it back called it the new
defenders which was okay it got canceled
again and in the 1990s they relaunched
it as the secret defenders amazing
concept terribly executed but the whole
idea behind this is that instead of
doctor strange facing off against
threats like dormammu or nightmare or
morphisto by himself what he would do is
he would turn to tarot cards and the
tarot cards would be read off and they
would essentially tell him who he needs
to gather for a particular threat it was
awesome because you would basically see
a team assembled that you would almost
never see under any real circumstance
and so this rag this this weird and
wonky team which was one of the best
things about secret defenders in the 90s
this weird and wonky team ends up being
yanked through time
and they arrive in this location that
they're completely and totally
unfamiliar with where they're met by a
woman who really doesn't necessarily
scoff with the idea that like they're
off world or that they are possibly from
another universe and we'll find out why
here in a second and essentially says
like on your feet right like the
devourers here we also end up learning
that like they're basically in the sixth
universe now here's the crazy thing
about this this devourer looks a lot
like galactus the problem is galactus
doesn't exist in this universe because
galactus has not been created right so
if that is not galactus who in the world
is it now we actually kind of pick up
with this devourer basically consuming
much in the same way that galactus would
right like like assembling its machinery
and preparing to to consume everything
and these people are basically trying to
survive as best they can now the funny
thing about this is this planet is
called top this is the home planet of
galactus right the home planet of galin
before he became galactus all they can
really do here is try to stave off as
best they can but what's happening is
this particular woman has essentially
created a device right now one of the
cool things about this is she has what's
referred to as a science fortress this
universe itself even as it's explained
by steven strange is a is really a
multiverse in in truth of science right
and that's one of the interesting things
here right al ewing's kind of changing
things up and not necessarily kind of
making a few adjustments in more recent
years pretty much all the development of
the marvel multiverse has really come
down to al ewing right during his
ultimates run there was huge
developments when it came to the
multiverse that had just never really
been explored before right like previous
multiverses different things like that
so honestly i'm cool with him doing this
because he's kind of the the the
full-fledged like reworking the entire
multiverse of marvel comics guy and so
what i'll ewing kind of depicts here is
that each multiverse was known for a
particular thing but the main marvel
multiverse right now i guess is maybe a
hodgepodge of different things i don't
know what it would really be known for
but the previous multiverse was a
multiverse of science every universe
across this multiverse was highly
devoted to science now a lot of this we
can assume is due to a genesis point
that every single universe in the
multiverse branches off of the main
universal timeline right just by like a
series of events and you guys know that
right we called the what if series like
what if this happened instead of that
happening so because it all is based on
a particular timeline if that main
timeline focuses on science more than
anything else then so would all the
other alternate realities as a result of
this that instead of having like
sorcerer supreme you basically got
scientist supremes is how this works
this particular person is the scientist
supreme of seemingly this universe right
she is the most knowledgeable scientist
in existence now the funny thing about
this is that in marvel comics right now
in the main marvel universe you have a
scientist supreme and i'm pretty sure
it's still hank pym i'm not aware of it
having changed but i'm pretty sure hank
pym still the uh the scientist supreme
but the whole idea behind this is that
the the fortress is kind of hidden away
so nobody really knows about it now one
of the things that happens in the middle
of this is harvey picks up on a smell
not the most important thing at least
not here in the moment but we also end
up finding out that in addition to
science this universe and really this
multiverse is not devoid of emotion
right like they have high emotions and
in fact this chick's kind of like yeah
man emotions run hot so basically what
al ewing is telling us this is a
multiverse of people who study science
and bank and that's basically it which
i'll be honest with you guys that sounds
amazing
[Music]
but we end up finding out the smell that
harpy is picking up on is coming from a
baby because this diaper was recently
changed and that's when this woman says
oh so baby gallon has awoken from his
slumber and that's when silver suffers
like gallon and then you ultimately
realize this is gallon right this is
galactus before he became a galactus
when he was a little baby right like
they've essentially traveled back to
i would even argue maybe a couple
decades before the end of this universe
right that's one of the weird things we
don't really know exactly how long
gallon lived for before the universal
collapse right i mean we can try to
assume a one-to-one ratio right so like
the average lifespan of any real
sentient being with a human-like
physiology would usually run anywhere
between like maybe 70 to 90 years
averaging around 80 years or so but like
gallon was from a different universe and
he was not human so while he looked
human we don't know right it could have
been that like they their guys normally
lived for like 500 years right and that
gallon was 450 years old when the
universe ended right we don't really
know
we're not really given a definitive
answer there now that we really need one
but but seeing gallons seeing galactus
as a child knowing what he's going to
become really kind of shocks the silver
surfer right it kind of stuns him
because he's like this child is so
innocent and so small and so helpless
right and it's just it's a little baby
and it has no idea and no one in this
universe has any idea that this child is
going to merge with the sentience of
this this universe and even the
multiverse when it collapses and he's
going to be reborn in the new multiverse
with a version of himself in every
single universe that will travel around
the cosmos and consume worlds killing
countless people in the process right
countless beings who would imagine this
innocent wonderful little baby is going
to become that and so initially when
silver surfer reaches for for a gallon
the masquerader pulls a gun right it's
just kind of like you know like almost
kind of thinks the solar surfer is going
to kill gallon now in reality you would
think the master raider would be behind
this but one of the clues to the master
raiders identity comes in a couple
different forms one the silver surfer
because of reasons right he kind of
chalks it up to the ability to read
auras right he basically realizes and
really knows who the macerator is more
so than that he knows the master raider
essentially knows how all this is going
to play out it seems that rast raider is
here more to make sure it plays out the
way that it's supposed to as opposed to
making any real changes or actually
fighting alongside everybody the other
part of this is that where silver silver
tells the master raider there's no way
you can injure me with a bullet the
mastery responds by saying surely you
don't believe that right like you know
who i am you know what i'm capable of
you know that time is the most important
thing to me you are aware i could
probably shoot you with the bullets that
i have in here and they will kill you
because the bullets are designed to kill
anybody because i'm wearing the the mask
of eternity and it makes me equal to you
so it's one of those interesting
concepts because while al ewing doesn't
necessarily explain it in fine detail
the indication here seems to be that
that not only is the masked raider
equivalent to the silver surfer in terms
of power but so is whatever it is that's
in his possession and so ultimately you
know the silver server is like no no i'm
not here to kill this kid right because
if i kill gallon i will never exist
right it would have just insane changes
on the timeline so if anything i'm just
going to keep this intact right it's
just so strange to me and so what he
actually does is he gives him a bit of a
gift that giving this this baby gallon
this kind of knowledge of the universe
itself right the universe that he will
be born into when he officially becomes
galactus will actually serve a couple
different purposes one it will allow him
to sort of navigate the universe without
really being unaware of how it all
really functions at least in the early
days of his existence given how long the
universe has been in existence right if
we kind of assume a one to one 13 and a
half billion years give or take galactus
has pretty much explored it all right
and even then if he hasn't his power has
reached such a high level that his
cosmic awareness makes him aware of it
all but more so than that when galactus
was initially born into existence he was
still kind of understanding his powers
and hadn't quite come to an
understanding of the effect he would
have on the universe itself and so while
i wouldn't say that silver surfer is
imparting this gift on galactus or on
gallon for the purpose of ensuring that
he doesn't become the devourer of world
i think he's doing it to make sure that
that gallon's able to sort of maintain
that human side of him right that part
of him that still feels emotion right
love pain sadness anger which might kind
of be al ewing's way of sort of
retconning in why it is that galactus
feels remorse even though he consumes
worlds right i mean you're not gonna see
him cry it's only galactus is gonna be
standing there shedding tears like well
i really wish i didn't have to do this
it was one of the things that always
kind of humanized you know gallon to a
degree and so following that what we end
up learning is that what is basically
the mother of galactus right the woman
that essentially uh created gallon using
a combination of her own dna and what
she referred to as a viable donor has
created something that's basically
called a mother cube now the mother cube
is a weird thing here it's not
explicitly given to us it is science
based so it may be one of these things
where it's kind of a blend between what
we would consider to be a cosmic cube
and the infinity stones the biggest
issue to this is that neither the
infinity stones nor the cosmic cube have
any real root in magic and so the way
that she explains it here which is a
really genius concept the mother cube is
essentially a containment device based
on the concept of the cosmic cube and
somewhat mirroring the elements of a of
an infinity gauntlet but more so than
that it houses emotion because this
version this this being out there right
this you know omnimax as she calls it
right this devourer of worlds is a being
that doesn't feel any emotion and so
introducing emotion to it is like
introducing a virus to a computer it
won't know how to process it it won't
have any way to stop it and so in effect
introducing emotion to this this uh to
omnimax is like introducing a foreign
antibody into your into your body that
your your immune system has no means of
being able to defeat it would kill you
right now the goal isn't necessarily to
kill omnimax just because of the fact
that it can't really be killed by
conventional means is to really just put
the fear of god in omnimax and just send
omnimax running is really what they're
shooting for and so once omnimax becomes
aware of their impending arrival even
though they're not really acknowledged
this leads to the arrival of the herald
of omnimax which is actually zoda right
like literally carlos zota this guy that
essentially escaped uh the master raider
from the enclave and was just thrown
back in time this guy is the herald of
you know omnimax in this past multiverse
and so a fight basically breaks out
between himself and the silver surfer
but while that's happening cloud uses
her energy to basically get the
attention of omnimax which successfully
works because these the sheer amount of
energy that clouds able to put out is
enough that omnimax is actually like
give me this energy right like i hunger
i need more of it keep feeding me right
and so while cloud can't feed you know
all the energy that she has otherwise
she'll destabilize herself and basically
die that it allows them a kind of
momentary reprieve where the guard of
omnimax is let down and this allows them
to essentially fire off this mother cube
which basically blasts omnimax with just
emotional energy that it never really
felt before now one thing that i do want
to point out here is that emotions
themselves as they're depicted here are
almost kind of running part and parcel
with magical energy right i mean it's
kind of raw magic as it's described i
wouldn't say this is al ewing kind of
copying like the emotional spectrum from
dc comics and all the lantern cores or
anything like that and i would say that
he's not really saying that emotions
themselves are magic but there are
concepts out there in marvel comics that
exist in this kind of gray area and that
magical control seems to be the only way
to really control those and that
emotions seem to be one of those which
makes sense right because emotions are
not rooted in science they're not rooted
in technology they're not really rooted
in any tangible thing that you can
invent like emotion is just a raw
byproduct of simply existing right i
mean you don't necessarily have to be
sentient to feel emotions right like
deer are not sentient but they do feel
fear although one could argue instinct
the important thing here is that stephen
strange while he can't necessarily
control magic in this universe because
magic in this this this multiverse here
it's like having a tv and you have the
wrong remote right you're not gonna be
able to turn it on and off or anything
like that that's basically where he is
right he can't control the magic here
because he's not native to this universe
or even this multiverse and so the
result of this is that he's able to kind
of direct it but he's not really able to
manipulate it absorb it control it the
way that he normally would be and so
that's why this magical energy is
directed towards omnimax which of course
sends omnimax in retreat the other part
of this is that where zoda was facing
off against the silver surfer because
silver silver has used the power cosmic
longer than zoda has he's more familiar
with it even if he's not as powerful as
oda which is one thing that's
established this omnimax character is
more powerful than galactus which would
make sense that his heralds are more
powerful than galactus heralds but the
the power that zoda has is offset by his
inexperience and silver surfer used that
that when zoda attacked him it created a
kind of link between both of their power
cosmic energies and the silver surfer
absorb those the result is that this is
essentially silver surfer as a herald
using the power cosmic from a previous
multiverse way more powerful than he
used to be that's basically what that
means right this guy is astronomically
powerful and so what ends up happening
here is that because of the use of this
magical energy they're kind of yanked
through time yet again and they're sent
back to the fifth multiverse the problem
is that when they arrive to this fifth
multiverse this is a multiverse of
magical energy this is a multiverse that
isn't really devoted to science it's
devoted 100 to magic which would
normally be steven strange's whole
repertoire the problem is he can't
control the magical energy here that
we're aware of because he's not part of
this multiverse the person who is part
of this multiverse is more done and let
me tell you guys something man mordon is
god tier this guy's level of power is
insane and i'm excited to see what
happens with these guys so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace
you